i would like to talk about genetic
algorithms they were
particularly useful for me during my phd
and i think
in terms of being able to build
something yourself and experiment with
them i think they're quite good bang for
buck and i think you can solve a lot of
problems
using them which would otherwise be able
to do so and even if you can't solve
them perfectly you get an indication of
what's what and i think that's pretty
neat
there's a broader category called
evolutionary algorithms and this is a
particular type of them
if you represent a problem in a
specific way you can evolve solutions to
that problem in a way which mimics
biological evolution and it's quite
visual as well
where we start is we have to have a
suitable problem
in order in order to apply genetic
algorithm um some problems
are more suitable than others and we're
going to do a toy problem
for this called the knapsack problem you
have a knapsack which is like a rucksack
or a bergen
and you fill it with boxes and each box
has a weight
and a value and the objective is to fill
the bergen
with the most value without going over a
specified weight limit
so a good way to think about the
knapsack problem is an aladdin's cave
full of treasure
so if you're in the desert and you had
one rucksack you'd have to fill it with
the most
valuable items and that's a very good
representation of this exact problem
we're going to do a simple version of
that
problem just because it's easy to
understand so we're going to have four
boxes
and each one has a weight and then we'll
write the values below which again will
be just
made up so if we do five four
seven two so these are our four
boxes and we've got a bergen here
and the goal is to put the maximum value
of boxes in this burgund without going
over a weight limit
so seeing if these are the weight limits
we're going to impose a limit of
15 kilograms so if the limit is 15 what
we put
into the bergen or the knapsack has got
to be less than
15. we can actually represent a solution
to this problem
with four bits so for either zeros or
ones
and each one corresponding to a box and
this one's pointing to this box
what this says is that the first box
this one
won't be included in the knapsack the
second one will the third one will and
the fourth one won't and what we can do
is then we can add up the values and the
weights to see
how well this satisfies this problem so
the weights are two and one so that's
three
and three is less than 15 kilograms so
what we can do
is then we can give it a score on the
value so we can actually return
the score which is four plus seven which
is eleven
so this solution here scores 11.
now if we were gonna do one which is
perhaps not so successful
so we can do one one zero
one this solution has these two boxes in
and these two boxes are quite heavy
so what we know with the limit being 15
if we add 9 and 7
that's 16 which is above the limit so
what
this solution returns is zero so this is
a useless solution we don't want it and
the goal is is to get
over time the best combination of boxes
so that we can get the most value
without being overweight so now we know
how to represent our solutions what we
can do
is we can make a population of solutions
which for now will just be
random so we got no idea how well
they're going to score
so this is our population that we've got
to start with
so this is eight randomly generated
solutions so what we did previously when
we defined the problem that's fitness
function so if we were going to write
that into code
what would happen is we would be able to
give it one of these solutions and it
would return how good that solution is
so what we can do is we can go through
each one of these
and we can get a score to say how fit
this solution is
we can put the scores here so let's just
have a little table so basically they
get the score of the value
but if the weight is too high to get a
zero exactly right yep that's it
so we've now got our scores so we've got
an idea of how good these solutions are
it's similar to survival of the fittest
so in general with this algorithm the
better solutions tend to survive and
propagate
over time what we do now is once we've
got our population
and we've got the fitnesses of that
population we do something called
selection
we have to select some of the population
to go
forward to the next step there are many
ways we can do this
one of the ways which is quite common is
something called roulette wheel
selection
where each one of these solutions will
get a
chunk of an artificial roulette wheel
and the bigger the score the bigger the
chunk
and we spin it generally if you have a
high score it's like you've got a bigger
chunk and you're more likely to be
selected
however that's not always the case we'll
do a different one which is objectively
quite good
and um it's easier to implement and
that's called tournament selection so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna have
a mini tournament and we're gonna
randomly select
two members of the population two
solutions to have a little battle
and the one with the highest score wins
these are just picked randomly so we're
going to pick
this solution and this one for the first
tournament
okay and the winner of this tournament
is this one so the best score here for
this tournament was
top one is that six and then we're going
to have another tournament between
say this one and
this one so these two have a little
battle
and it's this one that wins we've now
got
our two parents which we will draw here
so they were the lucky winners of the
tournaments so we've got
zero one zero one
for the other parent we've got zero zero
one one so then what we can do is we can
do something called
crossover which is when we cross over
some information from parent a with some
information from parent b
and we're going to do this by basically
splitting in half and just swapping each
part over
so the idea of this is that then we get
two children which have a little bit of
parent a
and a little bit of parent b and when
we're using a genetic care and we do
this according to it to a rate
so we can set a parameter at the start
called the crossover rate
a lot of playing with genetic algorithms
is changing the the rates and population
size so yes we're going to swap over
our two parents to create two children
so we're going to do
the first two so the first one and the
last two
and then so then we will have two
children now and we'll draw them down
here
so the first one zero one from here
and then one one from this parent and
then we'll have
zero zero from this one and then
zero one from up here so these are our
two children
so we've done crossover to get the
children so now we've got one
final operation and that's mutation so
we also have a mutation rate as well as
a crossover rate and a mutation rate is
typically a lot lower
than the um crossover rate um so
typically something like 0.05 0.01
0.1 something like that and what we do
is we loop over every bit of information
that we've got in the two children
and for each one of these we pull a
random number between zero and one
if it's less than the mutation rate we
flip
a bit okay so this mimics
mutation in nature the idea that
sometimes you can just get random
unexpected changes which adds the
variance of the population which over
time is quite useful so what we're going
to do
is we are going to flip just this bit
so now this child it's down that
what we started off with we had our
population we went through tournament
selection
we had a little mini tournament we've
got two parents
we then crossed the parents over in this
instance that doesn't always happen but
it did here
and then we've gone through mutation and
mutation has flipped one of the bits
from a one to a zero
so these are now our two completed
children
once we have our children here what we
do is we repeat this process
until we get an equivalent amount of
children that were in our original
population
so what we do is we go back to this
stage and we've already calculated the
fitnesses of every single member of the
population
so what we do is we just generate
another random tournament
so it won't be this one and this one or
it could be but it will likely be a
different tournament so we could do
this one and this one for the first
tournament and then say this one and
this one for the second tournament
and then we would generate another two
children and then we go back and do the
genetic operations on those two children
and then if we've done that twice we'll
have four children
so we'd repeat that process until we
have the same amount of children
as we had in the population and then
once we've swapped over
the population of children we've created
with the old population
that's one generation okay and typically
what we do is you run this for hundreds
250 500 000 generations and over time
what you should see is the average
fitness of the population gets much
better
and the best fitness gets a lot better
and generally what you see is you see a
curve that goes up and then it tapers
off at the end and that's generally a
good time to stop the algorithm
i'm guessing this is normally done with
a lot more parameters than four right
yes so you're exactly right this problem
is trivial it's more interesting if you
add other parameters so if
instead of having weight and value you
could have weight value and
size or additionally you have something
like weight value and
robustness so if it's like an aladdin's
k full of jewelry
you'd want to take the ones that lowest
in weight highest in value but
if two were the same in that respect
you'd probably elect to take a piece of
gold rather than a china pot because it
might break in your rucksack
so when you start having more parameters
it becomes less easy for
to see what exactly is a good solution
to this problem
and indeed how good a given box is
because some parameters are really high
and some are really low
you don't quite know where it exists and
when you start having a hundred a
thousand of these
this is when um jayhawns can be quite
useful they sometimes don't give you the
optimum solution
in fact they often don't but they give
you a good idea of what direction it's
going in
so you can get a better grasp of the
problem at hand this is a very vanilla
genetic algorithm
and there are some things that could be
improved and one of them is
if we look at this sheet here this is
our original population where we had
scores
this solution here wasn't picked even
though it was the highest so it was just
randomly not picked in this instance
but hypothetically it is possible for
this solution solution not to be picked
at all
and not to not be passed to the next
generation so there are some strategies
which you can use to overcome this
one of them is elitism which is where
you basically take the best
solution from the population and then
you put it in the next
generation anyway so you just remove one
from the the new eight that we had the
new population
and then just put that one in here if we
were gonna use this legitimately to
solve this problem
there are some parameters in here which
would be better if they were changed so
for example
the population size 8 is good visually
but generally
if we're going to start out using
genetic algorithms we use a population
size for something like
100 250 a thousand something like that
because with this it's very hard to get
variation
partly because we've only got eight
solutions but partly because the
problem's so simple
so if we did have value weight
and then we had size because some shapes
are better than others and robustness
and then we had a hundred boxes i'd
probably start with a population size
of 500 and i'd have a crossover rate of
0.5 so
crossover happens half the time and
probably a mutation rate of 0.05
and i'd use a tournament selection
because very rarely you have a
tournament selection size too
it's not particularly useful i have a
tournament selection of something like
four or eight those parameters just
loosely
should help um preserve the
heterogeneity within the population
to make sure that you have a a um a rich
space look through
because ultimately this is a search
algorithm this is just going through
this search space here to try and find
the best solution and if you solve other
functions you can actually
plot how the jet algorithm is moving
through a specific function
you only have to work out whether it's
worth alerting the user
if you find the key so you know you
download the temporary exposure key
you perform the encryption you generate
the potential
rpis and you compare them with the ones
you've seen or if you want a more
slightly comprehensible message
it's saying maybe you haven't applied a
function to enough arguments